daniel cohn bendit disait la semaine
dernière que entre push des mains des
rails on avait affaire à deux fous et
qu'effectivement il fallait une
médiation européenne ce que pour
l'instant refuse la commission je me
garderai bien de donner des leçons à qui
que ce soit c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible
il faut qu'on fasse très attention parce
que beaucoup de pays européens ne sont
pas l'abri d'avoir la même situation que
celle que nous vivons actuellement en
pologne
je pense notamment à notre pays la corse
1 entre autres mais ce que je partage
l'avis de florence c'est à dire que nous
avons quelqu'un d'à côté d'incompétents
et d'un autre côté un obstiné et
effectivement il ya peu de place pour le
dialogue et il faut que la solution soit
une solution politique de là à dire que
l'europe doit jouer le médiateur moi je
me garderai bien de tout ça je pense que
la démocratie espagnole elle démocratie
catalanes sont assez mûrs pour pouvoir
trouver le contexte dans lequel on
puisse effectivement avoir un débat
apaisé et trouver une solution qui
convienne aux deux parties équipe